Oh crumbling under the force of flooding
this cafe at hoi Khanh the Scottish
Borders caved and collapsed a storm Kira
blew in most of Britain was battered the
wild weather causing chaos from the
coast to the country as strong winds and
heavy rains swept through they've been
here before in my them right on the
banks of the river Calder in West
Yorkshire this is the third flood in
eight years the foot war the first thing
happens is the sewers fill up and all
the manhole covers pop off and so the
water itself that is staying in the
streets is full of all kinds of horrible
stuff that nobody wants to be walking
around in there could be many other
contaminants you know chemical stuff
that's washed off from farms and
warehouses and that kind of things 40
million pounds was spent on flood
defences here but they were overwhelmed
by the volume of water mounted time is
taken for him to do anything I mean it's
just second it means four years since I
last thought it should have been done
now hundreds of international and
domestic flights were cancelled those
that weren't faced bumpy rides
[Music]
this be a flight abandoned its landing
as winds whipped round the runway at
Dover ferry stopped running the Seas too
rough for crossings with winds reaching
speeds of 97 miles an hour it was a
struggle to stay standing across the UK
hundreds of thousands of homes were hit
by power cuts and on the roads dangerous
conditions a near miss for this lucky
passerby in Leeds while this driver in
Bedfordshire also escaped unhurt
sporting events were called off for
Public Safety and Royal Parks shut for
the day on the trains journeys have been
severely disrupted flooded lines in the
Northwest caused cancellations and
further south debris blocked tracks few
places escaped storm Kira and while the
worst is over a long and laborious clear
up now begins
Laura Bangkok Sky News